Adele will perform 'Skyfall' live for the first time at the 85th Academy Awards.
The British singer co-wrote the hit song with Paul Epworth...
...and saw it become the first Bond tune to debut in the Billboard Top 10...
...and the first nominated for Best Song since Sheena Easton's 'For Your Eyes Only' in 1981.
The performance will likely be a ratings boon for the broadcast in the coveted younger demographic...
...that led to the selection of Family Guy's Seth MacFarlane as host.
The film 'Skyfall' will vie for five Oscars in all when the show airs February 24th.
Adele said it would be terrifyingly wonderful to perform on Hollywood's biggest night,...
...hopefully not so scary that her performance ends in rumors of lip-synching,...
...as one did for a fellow diva this week.